chaque jour a dit jean ouverture du
procès de jean marie villemin neuf ans
après le meurtre de son fils le petit
grégory en fait jean marie villemin est
jugé pour l'assassinât de son cousin
bernard laroche qu'il tenait pour le
meurtrier
mais dès le premier jour du procès on a
vu que c'est toute la sphère grégory qui
était évoquée au tribunal dominique
verdeilhan jean marie villemin séparé de
la salle d'audience par une vitre
mesures de protection précise-t-on à
dijon et pour la première fois cet après
midi jean marie villemin va s'adresser
aux jurés je n'attends qu'une chose que
muriel dise la vérité sur la mort de mon
enfant jean marie villemin n'a aucun
regard pour le banc de la partie civile
l'a pourtant où sont assis entre autres
marie ange laroche la veuve de bernard
et surtout muriel bolle
une présence que les avocats de
jean-marie villemin qualifie d'
inconcevable pour eux muriel n'a pas sa
place sur le banc des victimes à dijon
elle ne doit être que témoin parce que
principal témoin à charge pour son beau
frère bernard laroche l'a utilisé de
façon cynique muriel a été son
instrument plaide m e thierry moser
elle ne doit pas assisté au procès avant
de témoigner
nous ne voulons pas d'un témoignage sous
influence enchaîne m chastan
muriel et bernard laroche ont été les
deux dernières personnes à voir grégory
vivant conclut m garot en face la partie
civile n'a évidemment pas la même
lecture du dossier
laroche coupable ce ne sont que des
hypothèses
bernard laroche n'a pas été jugé par
l'arrêt de non lieu de christine
villemin insiste m teissonnière
la cour a décidé muriel reste partie
civile et donc pour assister à la
totalité des débats le procès de la
dernière chance que commencer 6